hello and welcome to math simplified
in this video we will talk about the
five best shampoos that you can use if
you are suffering from dandruff
dandruff is a scaly and itchy scalp
condition
where clumps of skin cells come together
to create flakes
that you can see on your hair the white
flakes of dandruff can get a little
embarrassing for some
particularly if you are wearing dark
clothes but the condition is generally
harmless
if you are having mild to moderate
dandruff treating it with over the
counter shampoos can often help
keep flakes itching and irritation at
bay
according to a houston-based
dermatologist dr sunil chilikori
dandruff affects about 50 percent of the
world's population today
so if you have dandruff the good news is
you're not alone
in our previous videos about dandruff we
have discussed in detail about why
dandruff occurs
how you can prevent it and its treatment
so make sure to watch that video so you
have a clear understanding
of how and why dandruff occurs as this
will help you to know about dandruff and
how to manage it
when you start to look at anti-dandruff
shampoos it is important to know that
dandruff
usually occurs due to a combination of
the three following factors
the presence of malassezia yeast on the
scalp
the sebaceous gland function and
overproduction
and your body's immune response to the
presence of malassezia yeast on your
scalp
as a result most dandruff shampoos
contain ingredients that aim to reduce
the growth of yeast on the scalp
or to keep the sweat glands from
producing too much oil
now let's talk about the five best
shampoos that i have found to be the
most effective
working in my dermatology residency and
we will also talk about the chemicals
that are present in these shampoos and
how they work
so let's begin number one nisoral
anti-dandruff shampoo
nizoral anti-dandruff shampoo contains
ketoconazole 1
which helps in relieving flaking scaling
and itching caused by dandruff
ketoconazole is an azole antifungal drug
that acts by interfering with the
synthesis of the cell ball of the fungi
that causes dandruff without a proper
cell wall these fungi cannot grow
properly
and soon die out this shampoo is
specially formulated to be gentle
and it is also safe enough to be used on
color treated
chemically processed and gray hair i
have found good response in most of the
patients that i have recommended this
shampoo
use this shampoo twice weekly for at
least 6 to 8 weeks
you will see the benefits in just a few
weeks but it is very important to
continue using the shampoo for at least
a couple more weeks
to prevent the regrowth of the fungus
and also remember to leave it on the
hair and scalp
for several minutes before rinsing
neutrogena t cell shampoo the second
shampoo that i recommend for dandruff
and seborrheic dermatitis is the
neutrogena t
sal three percent salicylic acid shampoo
the t cell is a clear thick shampoo that
is both fragrance free and virtually
odourless
it foams up very good but this shampoo
lacks any harsh sulfates
salicylic acid which is the main
ingredient of the shampoo exfoliates the
skin of your scalp and removes the dead
cells
it gets rid of the buildup of dandruff
and sebum clumps on your scalp
it's a particularly popular ingredient
with many dandruff patients
and can help to get rid of buildup of
dandruff caused by seborrheic dermatitis
when examining the ingredients of the
shampoo i was amazed to see that it
contains only one
known contact allergen the almost
ubiquitous
cocoa amido profile betaine which is a
foam booster
the rest of the ingredients are
non-irritating to the vast majority of
us
which is absolutely fantastic just keep
in mind that
salicylic acid can also lead to dryness
of scalp if used excessively
so try to use this shampoo only once or
twice weekly for a couple of months
number three scalpy expert anti-dandruff
shampoo
scalpy anti-random shampoo has been in
existence for more than 17 years
the brand has a proven track record in
the treatment of dandruff related issues
it is based on the combination of
ketoconazole and zpto formulation
it contains ketoconazole two percent
which like we discussed
prevents the fungi to grow on our scalp
by preventing the fungi to form a proper
cell wall
zpto or zinc pyrethione is a
coordination complex of zinc
it has fungi static action which means
it inhibits the multiplication of fungal
cells on the scalp
and it is also bacteriostatic which
means it also inhibits the bacteria
growth on your scalp
people suffering from hair loss hair
damage and dandruff
or any other skin infection can use this
shampoo
after recommending many shampoos to my
patients i can comfortably say
that i have seen a very good response
with the shampoo
make sure to lather it up when you
shampoo and leave it on for four to five
minutes so you can have a good
anti-fungal effect
again use the shampoo for six to eight
weeks to have a good effect
number four cells in blue anti-dandruff
shampoo
cells in blue is one of the best selling
anti-dandruff shampoos in usa
selenium sulfide is a harsher active
ingredient in anti-dandruff shampoos
it's also proven to be relatively
effective as well
selenium sulfide in its one percent
concentration is too weak
and only effective for mild forms of
dandruff
but if you are experiencing anything
more severe then i would recommend the
cells in blue shampoo with 2.5
strength selenium sulfide treats the
excess shedding and irritation by
eliminating
excess scalp fungus and controlling the
rate of shedding of dead skin cells
in addition to controlling the symptoms
of dandruff selenium sulphide is also
used to treat
bitrisis versicolor a fungal infection
of the skin
antenia capitis which is a fungal
infection of the scalp
use this shampoo twice weekly for at
least six to eight weeks to have a
long-lasting
anti-dandruff remission from dandruff
and like all other shampoos we discussed
make sure to leave the shampoo on your
scalp for at least three to five minutes
so it can have its maximum antifungal
effect
the last shampoo that i'm going to
recommend is the derma co anti-dandruff
shampoo
the main ingredients of this shampoo
include glimbazole and biroctin olamine
old is a topical anti-fungal agent which
inhibits the growth of malassezia on
your scalp
while pyrotene olamine is a similar
compound to zinc pyritheon
and inhibits ergoceroal synthesis which
also stops the malasia from growing
further and controlling the infection
the combination of puroptane olamine and
chlambazole
also effectively restores the scalp's ph
balance
this shampoo also boosts scalp skin
renewable process
reduces hair fall and promotes hair
growth
also it is free from sulfates parabens
dyes
and other ingredients that may cause an
allergic reaction
make sure to follow proper lifestyle
modifications while you are undergoing
treatment for dandruff
keep your hair and scalp always clean by
following proper schedule of shampooing
and conditioning
eat a healthy diet do not share your
combs or towels with anyone
you can learn about many such things and
advanced treatment of dandruff
by watching our other video about why
dandruff occurs
by clicking on the i button above so
guys these were the top 5 shampoos in my
opinion
that you can use if you are suffering
from dandruff i have left
all the relevant links to these products
in the description box down below
i hope you learned something new which
will help with your hair health
thank you for watching this video if you
like it share this video with your
friends and don't forget to subscribe to
our channel
we are committed to bringing you latest
and better content
if you would like to support us consider
becoming a member of our channel on
youtube or support us on patreon
links are in the description box down
below thank you so much for watching
see you in the next video